BORIS SMUS: Cool.
So, hey everyone that's
listening.
We have no idea who is.
This is fantastic.
But welcome.
This is the first official
Chrome developer hangout.
And today's topic is Chrome for
Android Beta, which, as
you may or may not know,
we launched last week.
So maybe we'll go around
the table.
We have a few guests here.
And we'll do some
introductions.
So Marcos.
MARCOS: Hello, I'm Marcos.
I'm working in the Google
London office.
And I'm here for a
couple of weeks.
Nice to see you everybody.
BORIS SMUS: Peter.
PETER BEVERLOO: My name
is Peter Beverloo.
I'm a software engineer on
the Google Chrome team,
also based in London.
And I'll be here to
answer questions.
JOHN: I'm John [? Uffenbeck. ?]
And I'm also here from
the London office.
I've mainly been working on
various JavaScript APIs with a
support team.
BORIS SMUS: And I'm Boris Smus,
an engineer for Chrome
developer relations, based
here in Mountain View.
My focus has been on
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So I guess we'll start off.
Just as an intro, we
launched last week.
And the current state of affairs
is it's Ice Cream
Sandwich only.
So you can get into the market
but only if you have an Ice
Cream Sandwich device.
And it's only launched
in some countries.
And we're working hard
to expand that list.
So I think I'll start off with
just giving you a quick
overview of some of
the user features.
Hopefully you can see
this phone here.
So I'll unlock it.
And this is the basic interface
of Chrome for Android.
You can see we've completely
redesigned the UI to suit the
mobile form factor.
But essentially it's the same
Chrome experience on your
Android device.
One of the key integrations
here is that we have sync
enabled in Chrome for Android.
And that brings your Chrome
bookmarks, Chrome history, and
tab sync to your
Android device.
Just as a quick illustration
here.
I can see the same recent viewed
page as on the desktop.
And this is all synchronized.
I can see my bookmarks, again
also synchronized.
And this is a new feature,
tab sync.
And here this is a list of both
machines that are logged
into my account.
And I can see all the open tabs
from the last sync that
happened on those machines.
That's sort of the functionality
you get from
Chrome sync.
One of the most important
features of Chrome though is
speed, right?
The engine team has put in a lot
of effort to make this a
truly fast browsing
experience.
And one of the great things here
is we have pre-rendering.
So if I go to start typing a URL
in the Omnibox, set to the
New York Times, and visit
that, then loading is
accelerated by pre-caching while
I'm typing, so that when
we actually load the page,
it's immediately loaded.
And when the page is actually
rendered, you can see
scrolling is very
performant here.
So as I'm sure these guys will
tell you, the last three or so
months have been largely
spent on getting this
to 60 frames a second.
And they've done a great job.
So this is really
great to see.
Let's see.
Also we have this tab
management UI.
And it supports a
whole bunch of--
you can have a lot
of tabs open.
I don't even know if
there's a limit.
Maybe there is.
But the great thing that Chrome
does to make this
happen is it's very aggressive
about storing inactive tabs,
essentially saving them to--
like swapping the amount of
memory and only keeping one or
two active tabs in
the program.
So this makes the experience
very fast even if you have a
lot of tabs open.
But I must say, my favorite
feature, as a web developer,
remote debugging.
So I'll quickly give you a run
through of how this looks.
So I guess I should screen share
at this point, yeah?
OK, I'll screen share.
And my screen share is
not showing up here.
So the way you can get this
going is you run this command
to forward the port.
First, I have my device
obviously
plugged in through USB.
Run the command.
And then this will enable
forwarding.
And you then need to enable the
feature of the switch back
to the camera here.
You need to enable
remote debugging
inside Chrome for Android.
And here it's already enabled.
And at this point I can
go back to my browser.
I'll just share my Chrome
Window here.
Whoa.
[LAUGHTER]
Hope you like that one.
PETER BEVERLOO: And that's
all from the
developer tools right?
That's amazing.
BORIS SMUS: You get this
inception view.
PETER BEVERLOO: We need
to go deeper.
BORIS SMUS: So hopefully
people can see this.
I'll just hit local host on the
port that I forward it to.
And here we now have a list of
all the open tabs in Chrome.
At this point I can go
into any of these
tabs and inspect them.
And here I have full access to
the Chrome developer tools.
I wish I could show you both
screens at once, but--
whoa, here we go again.
Anyway, you can see I
can inspect pages.
And when I select this element,
the same hover effect
happens in Chrome for Android.
So let me just, I'll do an
alert in the JavaScript
console, and switch cameras
and then prove to you that
this is actually working.
So there's my alert.
And this is great.
So you can pull the instrument,
your Android
browser, and get everything you
need as if you're actually
running a mobile website on
the [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
JOHN: Boris, if you slide
through the elements on the
HTML, you should be able
to see them go blue.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah.
JOHN: I think that's a
really cool feature.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah, for sure.
It's a great feature.
I would love to show it.
The thing is I can't
figure out a way
right now to show both.
JOHN: Scroll on down.
Scroll on.
Why don't you try scrolling on
the laptop, and we can see as
things sort of get highlighted
on the Android phone.
BORIS SMUS: OK, I'll try this.
So you can guys can see, I'm
scrolling now on the laptop.
You can't see me scrolling, but
you can certainly see the
highlights.
So a very, very handy feature.
OK, so as far as other HTML 5
features go, I've got some
basic demos here just to give
you a sense of what the
platform is capable of.
First method fixed positioning
and overflow scrolling.
This is a pretty common pattern
in a lot of mobile web
user interfaces.
Here you can see a really
simple test page.
I've got a header
and a footer.
And they're fixed, whereas the
middle section is scrolling.
So here this is implemented--
the header is implemented
with the position fixed.
Same with the footer.
And then the middle section,
this div element, has like an
overflow scroll or overflow
auto maybe on it.
So this just gives you this
native like experience.
And you'll notice also that if
I scroll and let go, I get
this inertial feel, which is the
same as what you'd expect
in the native application.
Let's see.
Flexbox Model.
Maybe you guys can talk a little
bit about Flexbox.
But basically, we have support
for the first version of
Flexbox, not yet the second.
But this spec is pretty neat.
PETER BEVERLOO: The Flexbox
Model basically allows you to
do a much more declarative way
of defining the shape of your
layouts, thinking more in terms
of objects which you can
rearrange using CSS, position
the scale using CSS instead of
fixed width or even
percentage-based widths.
And it basically allows you to
create complex layouts, update
them really easily with much
less effort than before.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah, like, for
example, this one here.
There's a Flexbox indicated in
the top level that says, I
want a vertical flow
from header to this
middle section to footer.
And in the middle section,
there's a new method for the
horizontal flow saying,
go from nav
to content to sidebar.
So instead of doing things
like CSS [? slopes ?]
and then worrying about clear
fixes, you can just implement
things declaratively.
And the markup here
is beautiful.
It's very simple.
It's clear and very
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
OK.
Oh yes, my favorite,
so multi-touch.
We've come a long way here.
Android Gingerbread
had a lot of--
MALE SPEAKER: Can you
move it up a little?
BORIS SMUS: Yeah.
Sorry.
So Gingerbread had a lot
of multi-touch issues.
It supported single-touch
very well.
But this is the Android
browser.
But there were definitely
issues with
tracking multiple fingers.
So this is just an example of
a game here that pretty much
relies on multi-touch.
Because one finger controls
the motion, the
direction of my chip.
The other finger is like
a shoot button.
This is a nice demo.
It's by a guy named
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
from--
I think he's from
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: I think
he's from Brighton.
BORIS SMUS: Brighton?
Yeah.
Anyway he made this cool demo.
So this is what I do know.
[LAUGHTER]
We have good multi-touch
support,
tracking multiple fingers.
I've tried it for, like,
five or six.
I'm sure we can do more.
It's good.
Oh, and we've also made great
leaps in hover acceleration.
So Canvas is now a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
And this is partly due to Ice
Cream Sandwich's native
hardware acceleration support.
So now we do very well on
benchmarks like these.
This is a speed-reading
benchmark from the IE team.
Essentially what this does is it
just flips through a bunch
of letters.
And you can see we're getting,
like, nearly 60 frames here,
which is pretty much on
par for my testing.
It's like
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
So we've done huge progress
in the last three
months of hard work.
So this is super exciting,
because now you can start
building very rich, dynamic
experiences on your device.
Yeah, so, I don't know.
Are there any questions
that people have yet?
Maybe we can talk about
something that they're
interested in before
we jump into more.
PETE: Uh, are there other ways
for people to try Chrome for
Android if they don't have an
Ice Cream Sandwich device?
BORIS SMUS: Yeah, so I believe
there may be unofficial ways.
But I don't really know.
I haven't really tried.
So you're on your own.
PETE: Um, and then the other
question is just to confirm
that you need the Android
emulator installed on your
machine to use the
debug features.
BORIS SMUS: I don't really think
you need think you need
the emulator.
MARCOS: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
You need, basically,
just the [? DB2 ?]
which is the thing
that connects.
And then the important thing
that, I think we just briefly
passed this up, the
Chrome side of it,
you don't need anything.
It's just the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
developer tools in there.
So there's nothing special on
the developer side, so you
should be able to use all the
tools that you are already
familiar with.
PETER BEVERLOO: [? A DB ?] is
part of the Android SDK.
So it should be fairly easy
to find and install.
PETE: So that's the end of the
questions for now, but I'm
sure we'll get more
as we progress.
BORIS SMUS: Cool, sounds good.
So maybe we can just chat about
more on the engineering
side of things.
Like what were some of
the big challenges?
We talked a bit about GPU.
PETER BEVERLOO: Obviously a
phone, in terms of hardware,
is completely different from
a desktop machine.
It's much more limited in terms
of available memory.
It has a lot less CPU power.
The memory bandwidth
is different.
And Chrome has this multiple
process architecture,
separating the browser and the
renderer in several different
processes for various
reasons, which
made this a real challenge.
The multiple process model is
something we did implement in
Chrome in Androids.
It does work fine, but in terms
of resources on the
mobile phone, that did impose
some really interesting
challenges.
Another thing which we ran into
is the readability of
text and websites.
Obviously the hardware for a
mobile phone and Android
device is much smaller than
your computer's monitor.
And in that sense websites
will load in
the zoomed out way.
In order to compensate for that,
we've come up with a
technique that's called
Font Boosting.
And Font Boosting basically is
a way to increase a text size
for important parts of a web
page to make sure that you can
read them regardless
of the zoom level.
We already talked about GPU
acceleration on the phone, and
then the tablet as
well, of course.
Part of that allowed
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Chrome GPU team to implement
incredibly well multiple
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], which
separates scrolling from
actual rendering, which is one
of the main things which
allowed us to achieve 60 frames
per second scrolling
and fixed position elements
on pages in a smooth
and workable way.
BORIS SMUS: Is there something
people need to be aware of to
make their sites more
accessible for
Font Boosting purposes?
Or is this just something
that comes free?
PETER BEVERLOO: Font Boosting
comes for free.
And there are a number of
heuristics which decide which
areas of the page need
to be boosted.
There is not really a menu
about it so far.
But the algorithm is still
under development.
We're still making many
improvements.
And so there still are a number
of changes underway.
BORIS SMUS: Cool, good.
Yeah, so I guess that's sort
of relates to your talking
about basically rendering
of sites that aren't
designed for mobile.
PETER BEVERLOO: Uh huh.
BORIS SMUS: But what about some
of the strategies for
making your site more responsive
for mobile, is this
something we support as well?
PETER BEVERLOO: Yeah.
Transit has been quite popular
over the past few years.
It's implementing response
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
for a website, for example
using media queries.
Media queries are something
Chrome and Android support,
both on Android phones and
on Android tablets.
And it basically allows you to
provide a good, clean way of
targeting a certain subset
of [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to certain devices, allowing
you to optimize the website
more for, say, a tablet or an
Android phone, and making it
more readable without having to
depend on [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
BORIS SMUS: So you can do that
with both CSS, with media
queries in [? text, ?]
or you do it in JavaScript,
right?
PETER BEVERLOO: There is
JavaScript API to actually
listen to media queries, and
actually listen to changes in
media queries as well.
And it allows you to have
JavaScript events listening
to, for example, an orientation
change.
BORIS SMUS: And the
standard-- sorry.
The standard thing is you
would just usually have
division points based on the
size of your device.
Remember we just walked through
the other styles.
PETER BEVERLOO: Generally
that's the case.
Of course, depending on the
browsers you may target, it's
also a solution to have a rough
size estimate for phone
layouts, tablet layouts, and
desktop layouts using
percentages for widths, which
allows just slightly more
flexibility over the Android
phones which might be used to
visit your website.
BORIS SMUS: Mm Hm.
Cool.
MARCOS: Sorry.
One thing that I was going to
mention is that we are very
data-driven with the
developer tools.
It's a real game changer,
because now we can actually
see what's going on and optimize
real deep the overall
experience and use the same
tools to get our data and the
performance data, and
then investigate and
inspect all the page.
The development side of it,
it's a real game changer.
I think it's a really cool tool
to optimize further using
all of this technology
we just mentioned.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah.
PETE: A couple of questions
from folks who are reading
questions in the comments.
Are you going to talk about some
of the new input fields
and native behaviors
like [? Apex, ?] or
anything like that?
BORIS SMUS: Oh yeah, sure,
we can talk about that.
Yeah, this is a pretty often
requested feature.
The back story here is--
let's see, I have the
forms list here.
The input tag can have a bunch
of different types.
There's text inputs.
Here is just a regular text
input and various other kinds.
In mobile browsers, typically,
at least in IOS and other
platforms, you've had this
customization based on the
type of input.
So in the password field--
that's a bad example.
In the telephone field, your
keyboard now switches to a
number pad, because telephones
are numeric.
But there's also this class of
input fields that are date
related, date/time related.
So here there's a date/time
picker.
And you can see when I
click it, we get the
native Android control.
Similar for months and
weeks and times.
This is all new in Chrome
for Android.
And we support it.
You see a whole bunch of
other kinds of inputs.
Does that answer the
question there?
PETE: Yeah, I think
that answers the
question quite well.
BORIS SMUS: Great.
PETE: One of the other questions
that came up is what
about the UA string?
Are there any modifications
to that?
What is the UA string today?
And what do developers
know about that?
BORIS SMUS: Anyone
want to get this?
I can talk about
it too I think.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
BORIS SMUS: OK.
Let me just, actually, open up
the [UNINTELLIGIBLE] here.
So we have a code site,
code.google.com/chrome/mobile.
And if you go there, then
there's an FAQ section.
And I'm not sharing this
screen, I think.
Let me do that.
Screen share.
Whoa.
Inception notice.
OK, so we have a user agent.
So this is all pretty
well documented.
Hopefully you can see this.
Basically we support--
there's a tablet version and
a mobile phone version.
So here is the UA string or
the mobile phone version.
This is pretty much public
information.
And I guess the key feature
here is the CRMO.
So if you're doing UA sniffing
and you want to detect Chrome
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] specifically,
I guess this is
what you would get.
I mean, we can talk about best
practices and the pitfalls of
UA sniffing, etc.
JOHN: Of course, future
detection is much better.
BORIS SMUS: Correct.
So using things like
Modernizr--
we'll just open that up--
is generally the thing
that we at Chrome
developer relations recommend.
So this thing, instead of
looking at user agent strings,
you can detect based on the
actual functionality that your
browser provides and
include or not
include various features.
PETE: Cool.
We got a couple others
that came in.
What about the web RTC
camera APIs, are they
accessible right now?
It says they're supported in the
docks, but Mark was saying
he was having some trouble
accessing them with his code.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah, so web RTC
is not currently supported.
The thing we do support
is this Android
browser style camera.
So basically there's
a way to--
this is a quick demo
of that in action.
And the thing that's happening
here is there's an input box.
And it's got a--
I think it's like--
[INTERPOSING  VOICES]
PETER BEVERLOO: It's
actually--
we have implemented
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
API.
A link to that you can find
on chrome.google.co
m/chrome/mobile.
And part of that API allows you
to use an input type file
element, which you get your
attribute which allows you to
toggle between video or steady
image save photo input.
BORIS SMUS: So if I click
here, this should
essentially pick the--
it forces the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to open the camera,
essentially.
And then this particular demo,
I'll quickly take a
picture of my face.
And there's a picture
of my face.
And then I'll OK it.
And we have demo effect.
Sorry guys, let's
try that again.
I swear it worked before.
So the point of this demo is it
will take my face and put a
panda face on top of
my face instead.
Hopefully this works.
So there you go.
My face is now pandafied.
And you can check it out.
Well, this is the URL.
Oh, it's out of focus.
But anyway, it's out there.
So hope that answers
your question.
[LAUGHTER]
Anything else there Pete?
PETE: Why don't you move on to
some of the next things, and
we'll come back to some of
the next ones shortly.
BORIS SMUS: Sure, sounds good.
So let's talk about--
I'll find some [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Maybe you just want to like--
JOHN: Yeah, sure.
So we support all the off-line
technologies that Chrome supports.
And that's file API, the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
XTP, web SQL, section storage,
local storage.
So it's all there.
And you can manage that in the
user interface as well and
clear out the storage as well.
BORIS SMUS: So like,
how do you--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOHN: You go into
Settings and--
BORIS SMUS: Oh, OK.
Cool.
JOHN: It's a much more coarsely
grain than the desktop.
But you don't have a lot of
space user interface wise.
But it's possible to create
storage, and see which sites
are using how much
data and so on.
BORIS SMUS: Oh, cool.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
JOHN: Yeah.
BORIS SMUS: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
JOHN: Yeah, that's
exactly it, yeah.
BORIS SMUS: Oh, sweet.
JOHN: So there you are.
That icon on the right,
there, is--
so yeah, you can see it up.
Some of those sites are
losing a bit of data.
BORIS SMUS: And this
means geolocation?
JOHN: Right, right.
BORIS SMUS: So that means you're
granted access for that
site to access your
geolocation?
JOHN: Exactly, exactly.
BORIS SMUS: Oh wow, this
is really cool.
I didn't know about this.
JOHN: So, yeah.
All the storage APIs are there,
and are good to go.
BORIS SMUS: And we also have
app cache support right?
JOHN: Right, right.
App cache also.
And [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
Gmail and calendar
applications.
BORIS SMUS: Oh, and by the
way, we do have cache--
I believe we have app
cache internals
available here as well.
Like if you want to clear
an app cache.
Do you know?
JOHN: Um, we should have
some available.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah OK.
It's kind of unstable.
All right, anyway.
Basically there's two things
you want to do with a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], right?
You want to store assets.
Or you want to store data.
So there's a whole bunch of--
we pretty much support
the whole thing?
JOHN: The whole thing.
Yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BORIS SMUS: So, read
and write?
JOHN: Yeah.
MARCOS: Yeah.
Awesome.
PETER BEVERLOO: And, of course,
file system API, which
allows you to go even further.
BORIS SMUS: Cool.
JOHN: So there is also one
aspect which we'd like to
improve in the future, which
is working pretty well
already, is to input
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
file, so you can upload files
from your own device.
And one of the things I would
like to support in the future
is uploading your own files,
like your Picassa web images
and things like that.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
files, but it's on the
radar at some point.
[LAUGHTER]
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
BORIS SMUS: Cool.
Sounds like an awesome
feature.
Let's see.
Any pressing questions?
Or should we carry on here?
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
BORIS SMUS: One of the things
that we now include for
game-type applications or
experiences with rich
interactive elements
is a request
animation frame, right?
So this is one of the first
mobile browsers to support
this feature.
And do you want to talk
a bit about it?
PETER BEVERLOO: Sure.
Request animation frame is
basically a relatively new API
which allows you to instead of
using a JavaScript timer or a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to trigger renderings or
change [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
for, say, CSS animations or
Canvas elements, it allows you
to ask the browser to decide
the best possible moment to
open a new draw for you.
That has a number of benefits.
For example, it allows the
browser to inform your web
page that it's currently on the
background, so not usable
to the end user.
And especially on the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] with limited
battery and limited CPU usage,
you don't want to see it on
the website and have another
website on the background
create all these awesome,
3-dimensional effects.
I don't know what API, which
is making everything slow.
And using the request animation
frame can actually
help you in saving battery
power and increasing
performance.
For example the GP accelerated
Canvas users.
BORIS SMUS: Cool.
Yeah.
Actually you reminded me
of a thing that I'd
like to show here.
You said 3D stuff,
cool 3D stuff.
So there is a quick demo that
I'd just like to show.
This is not Canvas.
This is CSS animation.
But just to give you a
sense of the sorts of
things you can do.
This is just using CSS
animations, no JavaScript at
all, just key frames.
And it's pretty much running
very smooth.
I don't know if the stream
is good enough to tell.
But I think it's like 30, 60,
somewhere in between, frames
per second.
So this is really cool.
It opens up a whole world of
possibilities for developers.
PETER BEVERLOO: And the sites,
the CSS animation, are
actually animating it.
The 3D pics can be created using
the CSS 3D transforms
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
BORIS SMUS: Yeah, as far as
the transitions, right?
PETER BEVERLOO: Yeah.
3D transitions here.
But you could also
use transitions.
There are a number of websites
which have, for example, a
tilted menu in 3D space.
BORIS SMUS: Cool.
So we had a question
I think about--
PETE: Yeah, so Bernard wanted
to know, which countries and
devices are supported with
Chrome for Android?
BORIS SMUS: Countries,
I think there's a
list probably on our--
the Chrome consumer site?
PETER BEVERLOO: Yeah, there is a
list available on the Chrome
help pages on google.com.
PETE: We'll post that
in the comments
in a couple of minutes.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah, sounds good.
PETE: And what about
devices or--
BORIS SMUS: Devices, I think
pretty much all the official
Ice Cream Sandwich devices
support it.
PETER BEVERLOO: Yeah.
BORIS SMUS: Which is Galaxy
Nexus, Nexus S, and the Zoom
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PETER BEVERLOO: Yeah, and new
devices which will be updated
to Ice Cream Sandwich should
also come with the ability to
install Chrome.
MARCOS: And one thing to
remember is that we literally
just launched this, this
last week or last week.
We're going to expand this.
It's on our radar to expand.
But a little patience
just because
we really just released.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah, it's
been nine days.
MARCOS: Exciting, very
exciting things.
It's a baby.
It's just born.
BORIS SMUS: Anything
else there Pete?
PETE: No, that's it for now.
But keep your questions coming
in the comments on the
pro-developers page, and we'll
keep going from there.
BORIS SMUS: Cool.
Let's talk about device APIs.
MARCOS: OK.
BORIS SMUS: What sort of sensor
access do we have in
Chrome for Android?
MARCOS: Yeah, so we have
basically the same APIs that
we have on our own
Chrome desktop.
Geolocation we already
had on the Chrome
desktop for a while.
And then on the device you can
request for a high accuracy.
And that would turn
on the GPS sensor.
Of course that's if you have
that sensor on the device.
And then you have far
greater accuracy on
the geolocation position.
And then another cool thing
is the device orientation.
So we implemented on desktop
first. And it was kind of
tough to test, because we
tested on notebook.
And it doesn't make much
sense for you to turn
your notebook around.
And by then you probably broke
some hard drives just like
moving things around
and trying to
see if it was working.
It makes far, far more sense in
a real small device that we
can literally turn around and
move around, and see where
you're heading to and your
bearings and everything.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
MARCOS: So all this device APIs
are available for Android
and exactly the same for
desktop, only more useful.
BORIS SMUS: There's
a cool demo.
MARCOS: Let me show that one.
Just one second.
So this is a cool demo.
There you go.
So this is like a compass.
And using device orientation.
I don't think so.
And then, yeah, you can see
where North is just using
device orientation.
Here, try to move around.
So this is a great
little demo.
I just found out like five
minutes before I came in.
But it's really cool.
And it shows all the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
of the device.
And it's so much nicer
to do this on my
phone than my desktop.
BORIS SMUS: Right.
MARCOS: Oh, sorry.
BORIS SMUS: No problem.
Cool.
And then we also talked about
already, basic camera access.
So that's what we have today.
We'll see about the future.
OK.
Oh yeah, wait.
I was going to show a
demo in a tablet.
But I forgot that.
OK.
Can't do that one.
Let's see.
What else did we have?
Right.
So maybe just small things for
developers to think about when
they build mobile web apps,
mobile websites or
experiences.
So I guess the first thing
that comes to mind is
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
considerations.
So the basic idea there is you
want to be able to specify
which part of the screen
to show up on the
smaller display right?
Maybe you can elaborate
a little.
PETER BEVERLOO: Well, one of
things to keep in mind, there
is the meta viewport element,
which is also supported by
Chrome Android.
And it allows you to set
the initial zoom level.
If you really need to, you can
decide the minimum and the
maximum zoom levels there.
You could even disable
zooming.
Of course, you should only do
that if it's really critical
for your website to only be
available in your zoom of
choice, especially with
different screen sizes or, for
example, make comparison
between Android phones,
Android tablets that
could end up pretty
nasty for the end user.
But using that technique you
can also decide the initial
width of the viewport, whether
it should be equal to the
space width or basically
a width of your choice.
And together with meta viewport
element and, say,
media queries and using just
general responsive layout
percentage space widths, you
should be able to also use the
developer tools of course to
quickly get up to speed to
develop for mobile
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] devices.
BORIS SMUS: Cool.
Any other things come to mind
as far as mobile specific
considerations?
PETER BEVERLOO: Um,
not specifically.
MARCOS: I think [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
users is one thing.
Try to avoid type loops or use
request. Yeah, I think that's
an important consideration.
BORIS SMUS: Cool.
Maybe let's talk about the dev
tools and maybe some of the
coolest features that you guys
think are most interesting or
the mobile focus.
PETER BEVERLOO: I think one of
the main interesting things to
witness in the mobile phone is
the developer tools network
panel, because it allows you
to see the latencies and
basically the loading
performance of the resources
available for mobile websites.
And especially in terms of
optimizing for mobile
connections in which a route
we're trying to the server, so
to get in this file is much
more expensive than to
actually get a bigger file.
It's worth spending on the
network which you're on.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah.
PETER BEVERLOO: That can get
real [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
But I think that the network
panel can give some really
valuable insights.
Besides that, there is, of
course, the resource panel,
which allows you to see
everything which is being
loaded on the page.
You can see the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], all the
elements on the page, the
scripting panel for the
scripts, and modify
them in real time.
As far as [INAUDIBLE]
alerts, model dialogue.
BORIS SMUS: Right,
so the resources.
The resources gives
you a full list of
everything that's loaded.
PETER BEVERLOO: You can also see
the storage APIs, and the
various web SQL databases and
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
BORIS SMUS: This is
right [INAUDIBLE].
Look at that.
Very cool.
Profiling also is a big deal,
right, for mobile?
MARCOS: Yeah.
BORIS SMUS: Before this was
like very different.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARCOS: You have the day time,
you can actually make your
trade-offs and decisions and
optimize for the real thing
rather than just wishful
thinking.
You have concrete tools.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah, so you can
get a full breakdown of
exactly what part of
your app is slow.
So if I start profiling.
Let's see if this
actually works.
Scroll around.
We're profiling Google
Maps here.
Wow.
We have a full breakdown here.
Whoa.
We get the full line
members as well?
MARCOS: Yeah.
BORIS SMUS: The code is
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
MARCOS: Yeah, [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
but you get
a complete picture
of your profile.
BORIS SMUS: Whoa.
PETER BEVERLOO: And, of course,
the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
profiler there is also the
timeline panel, which allows
you to get a graph of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] loading times
and [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
times of every familiar page.
And script execute sometimes.
And they're really quite
insightful as well.
MARCOS: Yeah.
BORIS SMUS: Actually going back
to the scripts here, and
see if this works.
Oh no.
Basically there's this-- one of
my favorite features here
is this pretty print thing.
It may be a bit ambitious to try
to print this little map
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
But we'll see what happens
just for fun.
So I pressed the pretty
print button.
This is going to take a while.
Oh.
So now we have, like--
now go ahead and debug
Google Maps.
You're set.
You can just set a breakpoint
online.
Wow.
We have 9,000 or 10,000 there.
MARCOS: This is pretty cool.
BORIS SMUS: Anyway, this is
a [? must ?] feature.
I mean all of these
things are game
changers for mobile devices.
MARCOS: Yeah, not just mobile
but right across the board
this is exactly the same
tools that you
would use on the desktop.
So you're going to have just one
single, very comfortable
environment to target everything
in the world.
So that is really very cool.
BORIS SMUS: Cool.
PETE: So, there's a question.
Again this is Mark, who's been
a great participant today.
Thanks to Mark.
He wants to know what the
difference is between how
elements are rendered in Chrome
for Android and the
stock Android browser.
For example he says, I
know Chrome supports
fixed position elements.
How does that all sort
of fit together?
PETER BEVERLOO: Of course the
Android browser and Chrome in
Android both share the WebKit
rendering engine.
But besides sharing, WebKit
basically has two main layers
in its web core, which is the
rendering part and then in its
WebKit, which is an API
browser itself.
And that API is important
because it allows the browser
to determine how a website
should be displayed.
For example, how rendering
works, how scrolling works.
And the Android browser has a
different API implementation
than Chrome for Android.
We actually share that API with
a normal desktop Chrome.
And it definitely can explain
the differences in how we
handle things, how we implement
APIs, and for
example you can change setting
with [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
It's one of the reasons why
we're able to provide a
consistent and nice overview
of everything the
base is able to do.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah, that's
this one right?
PETER BEVERLOO: Yeah, so cool.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah, and I guess
also there may be differences
in the web [? conversions ?]
that the two respective
browsers use.
PETER BEVERLOO: Yeah.
BORIS SMUS: We may be poised
to be more ahead.
I think because of Chrome for
Android being bundled.
It's available for the market.
Updates are available
from the market.
MARCOS: That's an important
point, because
it comes from Android.
It's [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So we'll be getting all the
feature support-- all the
features that make sense on a
mobile device that we get from
Chrome desktop, because we're
sharing exactly the same web
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
as at home.
And the other browser shows
a slightly different--
we share the same web
core, but we might
get it slightly different.
But Chrome for Android is
exactly the same as Chrome
desktop with, of course,
some additions.
And this is very important going
forward, that we will be
following Chrome model.
BORIS SMUS: And I guess it's
important to point out that
lately the focus of the
engineering team has been to
upstream as much code as
possible to the open source
Chrome project.
MARCOS: That's the reason
we're here in sunny
California.
PETER BEVERLOO: Right now what
we're doing is if you go to
chrome.google.co
m/chrome/mobile, on the
frequently asked questions
page, there is a link.
If you want to see the source
code, at least the important
source code right now of Chrome
on Androids, what we're
doing right now is getting rid
of the differences and adding
all our source codes to Chromium
and [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to make sure that we can become
consistent as soon as possible.
BORIS SMUS: Whoa.
Sorry.
I was just trying to show that
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] page.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Anyway, [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Sorry.
Anyway--
yeah, so there's a question,
right Pete?
PETE: Yeah, so there was a
question wanting to know--
sorry, I'll try to find it.
When will it be available
for other countries?
And then as well, can you say
anything about supporting the
Chrome web store?
BORIS SMUS: So we're
working hard to
expand to other countries.
But I don't think there's
any concrete plans--
MARCOS: Anytime soon, I think,
is the real answer.
But--
BORIS SMUS: Sometime
hopefully.
MARCOS: --we'll be everywhere.
It's literally just a baby,
so please bear with us.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah, it's
been nine days.
MARCOS: Read your [? feet, ?]
like babies poems. It won't
be available anytime soon.
BORIS SMUS: Hey Mark.
MARK: Hey guys.
Thanks for doing this hangout.
BORIS SMUS: So anyway, I'm
trying to screen share this,
but I can't.
The other question was to do
with the Chrome web store and
support for that.
So yeah, there's no plans.
Again, we launched nine days
ago, so no plans for this.
And I would love to share a page
with a bunch of resources
where you can log bugs,
ask questions.
MARCOS: We can send the
links on anytime.
PETE: Yeah, so we'll go through
the links after.
But Mark had another
question that he
posted in the comments.
Mark, how about you ask
it actually in person?
MARK: OK.
So I've been using it out
of Transformer Prime.
PETE: Mark, I think
you're muted.
Oh, there we go.
MARK: Oh, great, OK.
I have a Transformer Prime.
And I've been using Chrome on
that for the last few days.
It's been working great.
But I have had a few
times where it's
had some weird bugs.
And I was wondering what is the
best way to report those
to you guys?
BORIS SMUS: Mark, could
you repeat?
We missed the first part.
MARK: Oh, sure.
So basically I've just been
using Chrome over
the last few days.
BORIS SMUS: The last,
file bugs.
So the best way to file bugs
is we've made a short link.
Basically, you go to
new.mcrbug.com, and that will
take you directly to the
Chromium bug tracker with the
correct bug template.
And then you just fill
that form in.
And you're set.
On that note, actually what I
was trying to show, and I
still am failing to
screen share.
If you go to mcrbug.com, it will
give you a list of all
the bugs logged against ASOS
Android, which is the new
component, in the Chromium bug
track that tracks mobile
issues, or that tracks Chrome
for Android issues.
And the cool thing there
is you can see
the number of stars.
And it's actually by default
ranked in star order.
So you'll see things like web
DL support, which is highly
ranked, as well as
other things that
people have been logging.
Those are the two bug
logging venues.
And if you have developer
questions, we're trying to
encourage people to ask them on
stack overflow, using both
the Google-Chrome tag, as
well as the Android tag.
So if you log your question
with both tags, then that
automatically goes into
my inbox basically.
And we have other people looking
at that as well.
So that's the best
way to do that.
OK.
So we're pretty close
to the end actually.
Oh yeah, so I heard there's an
Easter egg somewhere in the--
MARCOS: Is there?
PETER BEVERLOO: We've
heard that too.
BORIS SMUS: OK.
All right.
Well, maybe you guys will
find it sometime.
MARCOS: [INAUDIBLE]
BORIS SMUS: Anyway, so we
talked about feedback.
Give feedback to the eng team.
We talked about the
code sites.
So
code.google.com/chrome/mobile.
PETER BEVERLOO: And in addition
to that, the Chrome
site also has excellent
documentation available on how
to install the Android SDK,
and to start using the
developer tools.
BORIS SMUS: Right.
That's a good guide.
There's also a video, just
walking through, as well as
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] a site for
Chrome developer tools.
So there's a whole page about
how to use that stuff.
And we should include that
as a link in here.
Other things--
oh yes.
HTML5 Rocks.
So HTML5 Rocks is a great
resource for a lot of the
HTML5 features that we
talked about here.
There's actually a specific
mobile page that, again, will
link you to.
But there's general web platform
features such as
index DB and [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
will go to
index DB on that page.
So if you have questions
related to that kind of
technology, it's a good
go-to place for you.
So maybe we'll take any
last-minute questions
if there are any.
PETE: Looks like we've addressed
pretty much all the
questions that everybody's
asked.
BORIS SMUS: Great.
PETE: Thanks everybody
for participating.
I'll let you--
BORIS SMUS: Yeah, I don't
know if you guys have
anything else to add.
PETER BEVERLOO: If you can,
try Chrome for Android.
It's really good.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah, I'll
second that.
MARCOS: And we're here
for a long term.
So don't worry.
Just nine days.
We will expand.
BORIS SMUS: One more thing.
We have a Google+ page.
You can follow the Chrome
developers Google+ page.
And we post a bunch of links,
multiple times a day I think,
around various things
with Chrome.
There's something else
I wanted to say.
Oh yeah, we're going to try to
do more of these hangouts in
the future.
So right, we have a schedule
every Thursday.
We will talk about things other
than Chrome for Android,
as well as Chrome for Android,
so join us then.
All right.
See you guys later.
Bye bye.